If you remember from the lesson on learning, we talked with Dr. Zeligs. She
took some time out to talk with us about animals and personalities. So before I
move forward, let's take a look at what she had to say about the personalities
of some of the animals that she's worked with. So some people are surprised to
know that animals have distinct personalities. And you have a ton of experience
with animals, so can you tell us a little bit about your experience with their
personalities? Now, what's amazing is animals run the same gambit of
personalities as you see with human beings. You have animals who are really
excited and engaged and task-driven. You have animals who are really
relaxation-driven, who like to sit back and enjoy and be quiet. You know, what
motivates someone runs across the gambit of things. So some are, are motivated
by curiosity and some are motivated by food and some are motivated by activity.
And all of these things make up some of what inspires, and then what makes up
their personality, what, what attracts their attention. And what kinds of
things they choose to engage in. So Sharkie, the sea lion is one of the most
focused working women I have ever met in my life. And she would like to just
have her job going on 12 to 14 hours a day. And as long as we could focus on
making sure she's a star 12 to 14 hour, she's a diva. That, that's her, her the
best life in the world for her. Callie on the other hand is a little bit more
cuddly, she's a little bit more playful. She's not so much about needing to do
a task as she is just being. She's got that relationship thing. She really
wants to be with her best friends. And that's kind of what motivates her.
>> What kind of things do they do when, like, if Sharkie is not working. What does
she do when she wants to be working? Like, does she try to get your attention,
or.
>> Yeah, Sharkie will, will do all kinds of behaviors to try to get your
attention. And she'll also take out her frustration on her environment when
it's not going her way. She's got that real diva thing, you know? So she'll
take her toys, and beat them side to side. Darnit, darnit, why isn't it my turn
to be paid attention to. She'll give herself a job by swimming really
frantically or doing spectacular jumps or, you know, trying to keep herself
busy. She's definitely not a couch potato animal and then other the other hand,
I've known loads of animals that sit back and relax and chill out when. When
it's not their turn, they're perfectly fine with that.
>> How about any other types of animals other than sea lions?
>> It's the same. I mean I can't say I've ever worked with an amoeba but even the
quote unquote lesser animals that I work with, even fish I have trained have
distinct personalities. Some of them want to hover over here and like this kind
of security and feel like they need security. And others of them are
extroverted. And are very attentive and curious. And that's, that's with
monkeys, with tortoises with otters, with everything that you can imagine. They
have just a different natural set of ways of interacting with their
environment. And you see it in terms of whether they act out in their
environment or whether they're more wary. How playful they are. How active they
are. What kinds of things they like and don't like. So where you see the most
extreme of personality is the long lived super social animals. And so that's
because natural history sort of require the most complexity in order to work
with their world. Their broad social world is, is a big component of it. So
that's where you see the, just the most diversity of it. Less, less programming
and more learning from the environment is what's, what's going on. You see, the
sort of, least personality in the animals that have a much more fixed action
pattern type of life history. So, a snake or a lesser bird. But even in those
you'll see preferences and attitudes towards collecting prey you know, certain
snakes will need it to move and other snakes don't really care. And you know
and what they like the warm rock but as long as it's high up here or that, you
know. So there's, there's all of that and it goes across the animal spectrum
for sure.